[Music]
all right
this one's for bart especially wow for
everybody but
bar i think you should pay pay special
attention um
chinese food no what else do you think
it might be about
is it about uh loving their kids
oh no no it's not about that definitely
not is it about
uh regretful wives
just kidding no but you're getting
closer you're getting closer yeah yeah
uh crazy parents um just yeah a little
bit closer
too hot hot we're getting hot so this
one is about
how your earwax can show
signs of depression and stress
and bart for those of you don't know
bart has pulled out black ear wax he had
so much that it made him deaf
he had so much earwax it made him deaf
this makes so much sense to me because
like i always think that you could see
your brain through your ears as a kid
so i'm like this makes [ __ ] sense so
he has a dark brain
it's a lot of stress between his ears
and his brain
how wet or dry your way you think too
much i don't know do you have messed up
thoughts up there no i feel like i'm a
pretty happy guy
do you suppress it maybe i don't know
nothing i know of
do you need to talk about it maybe do
you want some tissues
yeah have you ever smelled your earwax
yeah it smells bad smells
[ __ ] weird never tried that it smells
horrendous it's like [ __ ] mildew or
something i'll try it tonight
do you guys have wet or dry wet
wet very wet yeah that's not crusty it's
got a viscosity to it
it's a genetic thing my cats love it
they eat it
yeah they're always in there and like
in your ears and you're like okay did
you just sit there and let your
cats lick in your ear it like tickles
i'm like no
stop it oh no i'm sleeping
it's kind of good keep going seven of
them so like do they take
turns well the only two are allowed out
of the kitten room but
there's a kitten or three now and now
you're like are you like i don't i
haven't had to buy q-tips in like 10
years
i feel like nicki has a room where the
cats like crawl in and they have their
own little like
house they do for now for now it will be
a floor just pick it and then go here
kitty kitty no
you know how you have an itch sometimes
and you're like whatever and you're on
the computer
okay so i'm like this and then my cow
comes up and like and she like starts
going crazy for me i'm like no and then
i have to go wash my hands and
all stuff the asians have dry earwax
usually uh yeah yeah
it's supposed to be asians supposed to
have the drier like flaky kind my bro
has the dry one and he's
pulled out like cylinders oh really
yeah which have improved his hearing
because it's so crazy yeah
cylinders you mean like it's like the
it's the entire shape is the entire
shape of his inner ear it looks like it
but i don't know what the inner ear
looks like it just looks like a like a
cylinder like that sometimes
wow like hollow no no it's like a it's
like a thick body like it's a
densely packed pellet but i have always
had the wet one yeah when i flush my
ears out sometimes it'll be like a
densely packed like baby rabbit poop or
something
how do you flush your ears out yeah so
you can get like a um
you could buy it at like a drugstore and
it has like a little squeeze bottle
and you put what does it sound like
do you do it i've done it before squeeze
it in and it goes up and
it drains it out yeah have you ever done
a neti pot
yeah oh my god i loved it i love it too
then the nose thing yeah do you do drugs
no you put it in one nose and then the
other you get mucus sometimes if you
know you know
and it flushes it out and yeah it can
flush out all the mucus
okay so this company actually has a much
safer method
than q-tips or flushing it's this thing
it's a tool that um because they find
that like uh your eardrum can get
ruptured with
q-tips 66 of eardrum ruptures are from
q-tips
so there's this tool that can extract
your earwax and then
you can send a sample to the lab and
they can test the cortisol levels of it
and they can actually yeah really
yeah so the drier the ear wax the more
stressed you are
no not the dryer the the cortisol levels
what do people
go no no i'll go then so like let's say
little i've got a question let's say
you're you're you're like i'm [ __ ]
stressed the [ __ ] out right and then you
you get the ear wax and the cortisol
levels hella low does that just mean
you're a little [ __ ]
uh just you could just stretch that
wasn't my question
i was like i think it was like a girl
the same place to edit in a completely
different place
it's not a part you look i know i don't
seven years old he's like dad i'm so
stressed you you go oh really
and you're like you get tested you're
like you have no reason to be stressed
you know
just a little bit yeah no it feels so
bad for him when he goes through puberty
it's gonna be wrong um the company says
that they hope to transform diagnostics
and care for millions of people with
depression or cortisol related
conditions such as addison's disease
and cushing's syndrome and potentially
numerous other
wax is conditions but is earwax the best
way to check those levels i guess like a
certain amount can
can uh point to certain mental
cause you know like what if you don't
pick your ears like every month or every
week or whatever right so you're
stressed as [ __ ]
and then three months later you decide
to pick it out and then you do this test
it might have been old ear water old one
yeah old stress
old stress yeah can we talk about that
that's actually part of it so
um usually the way they take cortisol
samples is from like saliva or other
bodily fluids but then
the levels of hormone could fluctuate
but they say earwax is actually the most
accurate really what about jizzin in a
cup that's not that accurate i don't
know i haven't i
don't
um hair follicles yield less cortisol
than ear wax
really yeah when people test for their
stress are they supposed to be a little
test for the stress
like if they're like oh yeah i'm not i'm
not stressed at all and often they find
out they're stressed or they're like
i need to correct my life because it
turns out i was stressed but i didn't
know i was stressed
i don't think i need ear boogers to tell
me how stressed i am though i [ __ ]
know depression
and like um anxiety like actual chemical
stuff yeah that makes sense because when
you're going through a lot of that if
you don't know what's going on
there's normally like a traumatic
experience that lets you know you're
going through these things
versus like testing something is that
called lost into solves
um and this is normally oh maybe we have
different versions of what that means in
earwax the chemical settles and builds
up
over time indicating to doctors just how
long stress levels have been abnormal
so they can pinpoint like [ __ ] seven
months ago what happened
and it's hella accurate yeah i need to
do this oh my god that's kind of
there you go that old stress what if the
boogers tell you how happy you are
though
i don't know so the ears tell you how
sad you are the boogers tell you how
happy you are you should send both just
in case
you're like do they know the difference
i know because i think i'm one of those
people that like
uh i don't know i'm burnt out until like
months after i could see that so like i
think instead of
getting into a preventative measure
we're like oh this is gonna
i'm gonna i can see where i'm gonna get
burnt out let me
start taking it easy beforehand i think
this would help out yeah i think so
yeah cause that's what um a lot of
people get heart failure
and like but other bot like other organs
start to
you know stop functioning because of
stress and most of the time when people
have like heart attacks and things like
that they're like you know the leading
cause of that is stress but
everybody overlooks it like yeah you're
stressed [ __ ] get over it or go to
sleep you know whatever
why are you getting burnt out though are
you like are you ever just like i'm just
a big [ __ ] about this
no what's up that's not a very healthy
way to think about it
very nice very well-handed
when i farted and he smelled it and he's
like no i'm just a little [ __ ]
you call that cortisone nope there has
to be a day where we're
able to do these tests ourselves just
like naturally yeah have all these tests
and be like
okay stress levels are good you know how
like how people test their diabetes so
check that
yeah i'm doing a hormone test i know you
are like i need to do that
you could get one and test for like 100
bucks and then they do
all your vitamin levels your
testosterone
your stress whatever yeah it's pretty
sick yeah you should do that
elon musk is trying to do that neural
link [ __ ] it was from the same company
that i did
test from kind of down you're down i'm
excited
for people that are down i'm just not
here's why i feel like
i don't go to the doctor enough already
you know so then like now
instead of me going like oh i think i
feel weird i should probably go to a
doctor and try to give him my best guess
they can call me and be like hey you're
[ __ ] up come in right now think of the
lives that would have been saved even
during covet people not going to the
doctor because the covenant like like
all this all the preventative [ __ ] that
could have happened i tell you guys this
so my sorry sister she has a
like a pacemaker a defibrillator so what
happens is that like
it sends signals so she has to do
certain things and send signals let me
tell you
when that thing is not working or a
battery not here but the battery on the
reader
is off the panic it causes is
crazy it's like because you know what's
going on so there's somebody that can
tell like
how was your sleep last night what is
going on so you you want to know but
then at the same time it is
it's terrifying to her just injecting
she starts panicking or someone will
start calling her like
so she'll start panicking because it's
like she has to check
because there's certain checkups that
you have to do and it goes somewhere so
somebody's checking to make sure
everything is working so same thing like
you put that in your head
there's going to be a level of like
dependency that you have i'm into it
fine because our healthcare system sucks
facts
but that's one of those things where
like i said i'm excited for
you to try it because hey me too thank
you you know i'm excited for
people that want to be in it and i'm not
against them like yo if we're gonna find
a better way if i can find a better way
because i'm
i'm watching somebody deal with it but
it
is kind of scary at the same time i mean
but that's why i was like
would you choose to know which day you
die do you want to know or do you not
want it i don't want to know
that's why i don't read horoscopes yes
right if it's preventative
tell me as much information as i can get
right if i can help myself
so would you want to know like a daily i
don't even want to know if i had cancer
i'm thinking of the every man right like
a lot of people save yourself do you
want like the
it's almost like the you wake up you
know we wake up you know we wake up and
check our phones not me would
you're just so different this is what i
really like about you um
but like for for people like me uh wake
up check the phone would you want
a vital update like i'll be tight yeah
you're about to die today what about
that one apple watch is like that
with the heart [ __ ] and all that stuff
what i do is i have a sleep app
so right when i go to sleep i hit going
to sleep now because i track my sleep
you know when you're going to sleep yeah
i had to train myself though because i
had to figure out
what the combat oh it's not a psychic
it's not a cigarette
sex i i use sleep meditation too because
i can't just fall asleep but i
don't know when i'm following i don't
think i can say i'm falling asleep
i have a sleep number bed and it
actually tracks my sleep now that i
think about it yeah i have something
that tracks my vitals when i'm doing it
it does that too
like like i want to make sure that i get
enough sleep
but i don't want nothing in my head yeah
i don't like it in there
and they're not gonna like it it
actually made me more paranoid and then
i was getting less sleep because i was
like i don't know if i don't fall asleep
but this time then i won't get the
cause anxiety dude i can't wait for
today hey google what's the answer to
this [ __ ] question and it's like that
that that out of my mouth
that was the part that i was like i
can't wait till it's like matrix and i
go
i know karate exactly right does that
mean that we're going to be able to do
anything we're going to build [ __ ]
houses we don't even know what's going
on while it's happening
you know back in the day people knew how
to build houses yeah everyone needed to
yeah to survive yeah now everyone's like
like oh [ __ ] building a house i gotta
hire a guy all this [ __ ] those guys are
[ __ ] bro we're gonna know how to do
that [ __ ]
from an implant watch
[Music]
[Music]
you